I'd now like to talk about the
velocity of the center of mass
for a system of particles.
So let's take a system, which
I'll just outline by this.
And in that system, we have a
bunch of particles, particle 1,
particle 2-- let's refer to
this as the j-th particle
and some point xcm.
And if I want to talk about the
position of the center of mass,
I can choose a point s.
And if I want to
define that vector Rcm,
then what I have to do is draw
a vector to each object Rsj.
And we saw that this
velocity, the position
of the center of mass with
respect to this origin
s is the sum and mjrsj.
And that's divided by the
total mass and m total.
And j goes from 1 to n,
where n is the number
of particles in the system.
Now if I want to find the
velocity of the center of mass,
then I can just
differentiate this.
And I'm dropping the
point s for the moment,
but let's just
differentiate 1 to n.
And you'll see why.
And when I differentiate
the position vector
of the object, that's the
velocity of the object divided
by j goes from 1 to
n, the total mass.
Now why did I drop the position?
Because if you
have any two fixed
points-- so if I chose another
fixed point, say, over here p,
then this distance R--
we'll call it vector from s
to t Rsp-- this is a constant.
And if I draw position vector
with respect to p-- now
the point here is that this
is a constant distance,
because this is a fixed--
these are fixed points.
Then if you were to draw
your vector triangle, which
is the position of the
object with respect to s--
that's this vector-- is
equal to that fixed position
vector from s to p, plus
the vector from p to j,
and I differentiate
this, drs jdt.
Well, this derivative of
a constant vector, this
is 0 plus drp jdt.
And so we see that
the velocity j
is independent of the
choice of point s.
You choose any other
fixed point and you
get that velocities
drs jdt equals
drp jpt for all fixed points p.
And that's why in
this expression, when
we differentiate the velocity,
even though we had an index s,
we dropped that.
And so our conclusion
is that we can
treat that we have the
velocity of the center of mass
of this system is
equal to the sum mj vj.
j from 1 to n divided
by the total mass.
Now what's interesting
here is, why
is this an important quantity?
Let's just add that
if we want to talk
about the acceleration
of the center of mass,
I do exactly the same
type of calculation.
I just differentiate.
And I get the mass
of the j-th particle
times the acceleration of
the j-th particle divided
by the total mass.
And our next step
is to understand
why this is an
important quantity
for a system of particles.